the courage to lead this one is
embarrassing that has to be on the list
but nonetheless it must because
everything that I have explained to you
today is unbelievably difficult it is
extremely hard to make decisions with a
just cause in mind when so many of the
pressures on all of us are pushing us to
make the finite short-term decisions if
you work for a public company the
pressure is overwhelming from the
outside to focus on the finite at the
expense of the infinite sometimes we put
pressure on ourselves to focus at the
finite we'd be so become so obsessed
with the arbitrary goals we set for the
end of the year that sometimes we
abandon our own values in order to make
the sale gain the client move the
numbers and if we do that too many times
over the course of years it's to the
detriment of our own organisations it's
to the detriment of our own people it is
unbelievably hard to keep a Just Cause
in mind as the guiding principle is
especially if you have to make decisions
that hurt in the short-term it is
unbelievably to commit yourself to this
lifestyle this practice of good
leadership where you obsess about the
trusting teams like a family it's never
perfect it's about human relationships
sometimes it's confounding to us and yet
for us to acknowledge that our
responsibility as leaders is not to
drive the results but to create an
environment in which our people can work
at their natural best is unbelievably
difficult it is so much easier just as
hire and fire people willy-nilly and
drive the numbers and create all kinds
of incentive structures based solely on
someone's performance except for the
fact that it drains the energy of people
it drains the trust of them that
inhibits cooperation and innovation and
eventually it runs out of steam it's
hard it's much easier to direct all of
that discomfort and anxiety we have
about competitions and our weaknesses at
others but the problem is if we become
so obsessed at winning sometimes we do
things that are quite unethical if it's
like running in a race where I'm
obsessed with beating the other runner I
may resort to tripping him I may win the
race
but I'm still a slow runner and in this
game there is no end of the race it
keeps going and going and going and
going and going and going and going
and to change our mindset away from
having competitors to having worthy
rivals and being honest with ourselves
about our weaknesses is unbelievably
hard the capacity for existential
flexibility most people in this room
will never have to do it not once
however are you building your
organization so that the organization
and future leaders have are prepared to
be able to do it do the people know that
just cause that is it a culture of
trusting teams so that future leaders
can make the Flex if they need to even
if you've never had to that's the
responsibility of leadership to prepare
the organization for the next leaders if
you are perfectly satisfied with the
fact that when you quit your company
will go belly up I got no no beef with
that just be honest about it you're
playing a finite game and it's just for
fun and you're gonna see how much you
can accumulate in your time there and
then you're done
it's no problem with that but some
people have an ambition that the company
can outlast them and even grow greater
than when they ran it kind of like the
same ambition we have for our children
that's hard it's hard to maintain an
infinite mindset it's hard to adopt an
infinite mindset it takes unbelievable
work and it takes unbelievable courage
the company CVS the chemists in the
United States had a vision statement had
a just cause that they would protect the
health of their employees and their
customers and they kept finding
themselves in these very uncomfortable
meetings they would be meeting with
hospitals and doctors and they'd have a
wonderful meeting about how they could
partner together the chemists and the
and the medical professionals and at the
end of the meeting somebody would say
don't you sell cigarettes and so one
year they decided that they were gonna
remove all the cigarettes from all of
their shops it there's a move that would
cost them billions of dollars of revenue
billions with a be Wall Street lashed
out against them at the announcement
they stuck to their guns analysts said
silly things like those cigarette sales
will now go to other places predicting
the future and yet when all the sales
where all the cigarettes removed out of
their stores something half
sailes either stay the same or went up
turns out although cigarette sales
didn't go somewhere else
when end up happening is more people
stopped smoking in the towns in which
CVS has existed in fact would also
happen as people were so enamored by the
fact that they were making that they
would make such a courageous decision
based on cause and not money that people
spent more money at CVS or travel out of
their way in order to do business with
CVS and the employees spoke with
remarkable pride about how much they
loved working at this company that was
so courageous that was willing to do the
right thing over the expedient thing
their competitors rite-aid
and booths their CEOs were interviewed
and asked are you going to remove
cigarettes from your stores incidentally
both those organizations had vision
statements on their websites you guessed
it to protect the health of our
customers same vision and yet Rite Aid
said we're continuing to examine the
situation and we continue to sell
smoking secession products in other
words they're gonna sell a nicotine
patch next to a pack of cigarettes which
is much like selling a doughnut next to
a diet book right one is an impulse
decision the other one requires a little
work turns out even somebody who wants
to go on a diet still buy as a doughnut
if you offer them the opportunity boots
was even funnier they said that we are
selling cigarettes in compliance with
all local state and federal laws that's
not courage the law is a much lower
standard than ethics and this is one of
the problems we have in the world today
it's a standard of business is too low
the standard of modern business is
predominantly driven by a theory
proposed in the 1970s by a name made by
a man named Milton Milton Friedman
Milton Friedman was an economist who
gave us the responsibility of business
he said the responsibility of business
is to maximize profit within the bounds
of the law that is a very low standard
let me show you what the bounds of the
law produces when the Titanic was built
it was considerably larger
then all the other ships that existed in
the day and the regulations that
governed lifeboats in the day were
governed by size and not they didn't
have a lifeboats for all provision yet
and the largest vessels of the day were
ferries and the Titanic was four times
larger than the largest ferry so what
the Titanic's builders did expressly to
save money was put empty berths for
lifeboats on there on the decks of the
Titanic but they only put enough
lifeboats as required by regulation
which as it turns out was one-quarter of
the number of passengers that they would
be carrying because the regulation
didn't require it so they didn't do it
they knew that the regulation would
eventually catch up which is why they
put the empty berths we all know what
happened in 1912 the Titanic struck an
iceberg and sank and guess how many
people died you guessed it
75% 25% survived the Titanic broke no
laws in other words the law is a very
low standard it is not high enough
standard and unfortunately thanks to
Milton Friedman and people who embraced
Milton Friedman in the 80s and 90s so
many business theories were developed
based on this standard that the
responsibility of business is a maximize
profit within the bounds of the law the
concept of shareholder supremacy showed
up which means we prioritize the once
needs and desires of shareholders over
the once needs and desires of customers
or even employees this is like a an
owner of a football team trying to build
a great team by asking the fans what we
should do rather than asking the players
what they need doesn't work so well but
because of the 80s and 90s these boom
years the concept of shareholder
supremacy became normalized the ideas of
using redundancies on an annualized
basis in order to balance the books
think about that for a second we're
gonna use someone's livelihood so that
we can meet our arbitrary projections at
the end of an arbitrary time period and
companies use redundancies and layoffs
even when they're profitable they just
weren't as profitable as they predicted
think about the ethics for that for a
second
forget about the people who lose their
jobs think about the unbelievable stress
it causes to the people who kept their
jobs because what they basically been
told is this is not a meritocracy and no
one here is safe do you think they're
giving you their all the next year
no they're hiding from you and they're
lying to you and they're faking every
single day because that's the business
model we've provided the idea of Rankin
yank
where we promote the top 10% of
performers and fire the bottom 10% of
performers became normalized in the 80s
and 90s the evisceration of regulations
to protect us from speculative investing
were destroyed in the 80s and 90s in the
name of profit and now we've had three
stock market crashes in the past 30
years we're from the Great Depression up
until the 1980s we had zero in other
words we have an outdated business model
even GE itself Jack Welch was hailed as
a hero of business for everything that
he proposed he was a Milton Friedman
acolyte he became the poster child what
leadership looks like in the 80s and 90s
GE needed a three hundred billion dollar
bailout from 2008 and who knows if it's
even going to survive for the next five
years it was not a company built to last
it was a company built with finite
mindset for finite success we need to
completely reimagine business as it
exists we need to reject the finite
mindedness of the 80s and 90s and we
need to embrace the infinite mindedness
for the next millennium and the irony is
it's good for businesses it's good for
business the organizations that are led
with a finite infinite mindset those
infinite minded organizations tend to
outperform their competitors over the
long term they tend to have much higher
levels of innovation much stronger teams
where the people don't leave and quit at
the slightest shudder they hunker down
and say how can I help and for those of
us who are have to work there those are
the jobs we love all of this raises an
interesting question what does it mean
to live an infinite life
clearly our lives are finite but life is
infinite we're born we die but life
continues with us or without us
which means though we don't get to
choose the rules of the game we do get
to choose how we want to play in this
infinite game and we can choose to live
our lives with a finite mindset or an
infinite mindset to live our lives with
a finite mindset means we wake up every
single morning trying to make more money
than anyone that we know to maximize the
amount of power that we have to gain
power and sort of oversee the world
control the world domination and when we
die we leave it all behind
it's only fun while we're living can't
take it with you people hate us it
causes health problems you look at a lot
of these finite minded entrepreneurs
who've done really well in life and go
look in their medicine cabinets look at
the qualities of their marriages or
their relationships they have with their
children and it paints a different story
to live our lives with an infinite
mindset means we wake up every single
morning and think to ourselves how can
we even have a positive impact on the
people around us that one day I can meet
a remarkable entrepreneur a remarkable
business leader and say how did you
become who you are today and they will
mention your name they will talk about
the lessons they learned from you how
they learned to be a better version of
themselves to take care of the people
around them and then everything that
they've learned today came from somebody
else in other words you have literally
lived on beyond your own years I had a
chance to sit down with Sir Richard
Branson and I asked him a question I
said how should we judge you after you
die I asked him I said what did you
build at virgin
what about virgin are you most proud of
that you will want to be remembered
after you die and he got very annoyed
with me and he said do not judge me by
anything that I have ever done at virgin
he says if you want to judge the quality
of my life you judge the quality of my
children that's an infinite mindset
every single one of us has a choice
whether we want to live our lives with a
finite mind set or an infinite mind
it is just a choice
[Music]